nabila nouvelle animatrice du nouveau
jeu ces landes qui arrive sur c'est quoi
cette chaîne d amazon prime à une forme
de s vod alors son ca n'a été dévoilé
alors c'est vous qui l'avez l'info
maxime de sud infos alors c'est combien
nabila et réussi à négocier est l'un des
plus gros cachet jamais signé pour une
animatrice quand j'aurai deux prennent
le groupe regardait millions d'euros
près d'un million d'euros pour un mois
de tournage fait cette saison donc un
million supplémentaire plus un
documentaire exclusif tourné des ja
magazine vidéo un nom est pardon une
patate love island trois patates a
beaucoup d'argent
alors oui alors les petites ya un gars
est derrière cela j'appris qui est une
grande négociatrice on peut le dire je
crois que c'est magali bertin qui a
négocié d'accord mais les chiffres parce
que je suis soumis au secret
professionnel dossier ce contrat et j'en
suis ravi je suis chrétien qui est un
gros c'est quoi ta comme sur -10% et de
respect ni à toi magasiner à nabila qui
franchement y'a pas besoin de diplôme
pour être animatrice dont on ne voit pas
pourquoi elle serait pas une bonne
animatrice comme voilà comme n'importe
qui moi ça me dérange c'est des chiffres
qui me dérange pourquoi parce qu'un déjà
amazon prime franchement personne ne l'a
donc déjà pourquoi
au moins en france on est quand même
très peu à être équipé c'est vrai qu'on
termine à melaka forme allait de mieux
en mieux je vais t'expliquer aujourd'hui
tan explique ce qui est numéro un sur le
voile sur ce genre de plateforme amazon
veut concurrencer netflix et une volonté
ils ont de l'argent
on va pas se mentir voit la france et
cette plateforme ils ont les moyens les
moyens justement parce que nabila c'est
un nom on a beau dire ce qu'on veut là
une puissance incroyable d'accord ils
ont décidé de miser sur et pour
représenter en quelque sorte aussi
amazon prime en france pour télécharger
cette plateforme et devenir numéro un en
france
alors bien sûr qu'aujourd'hui amazon est
moins connu encore bénéfique mais le but
de ces opérations
c'est que amazon de vienne et du
business qu amazon devienne numéro un
fait est sûr c'est que ils ont donné
beaucoup d'argent nabila mais ils n'ont
pas mis beaucoup d'argent pour le teaser
regardez c'est moi votre présentatrice
de laval ont une idée célibataire plein
d'amour trop de sentiments
retrouvez-moi le 2 mars seulement sur
amazon prime vidéo a commis
satanas de la villa c'est pas le teaser
de l'émission j'ai un autre truc c'était
un indice de regarder alors vous
pourriez vivre sans votre smartphone bon
les highlanders dont la thaïlande les
highlanders reçoivent en temps réel des
messages et des fois ça fait mal dans
love island le changement de partenaire
est un moment clé
c'est un peu comme mélanger un jeu de
cartes de nouvelles paires se forment et
la dernière can sera l'amour sont les
tate
dans love island les highlanders ont
vidé des complices au top et même des
dettes qui a été apportés de l'étranger
est ce que ça fonctionne ailleurs
secteur j'ai dès la 14eme adaptation en
france ça cartonne sur haïti vit
notamment en angleterre ont gagné un
bafta l'équivalent d'un oscar
c'est une chaîne et quand elles sont
diffusées sur des chaînes là en france
émission diffusée sur une plateforme et
petit récap sur le concept vous avez
ronces et les mater qui partent en
afrique du sud pour trouver l'amour sauf
que le téléspectateur va pouvoir
télécharger une application gratuite et
influencer sur l'histoire qui va être
racontée donc c'est un dating en temps
réel montée en temps réel par exemple je
vais choisir avec qui elle va sortir
avec qui je fais rentrer dans l'habitat
etc
il ya 60 caméras c'est un gros barnum
alors vous savez quand même c'est une
usine à vous savez que l'animatrice
la version s est suicidé dernière
terrible c'est avait été remplacé voilà
aidant pialat d'un procès on va chez
tout ça moi je n'ai pas pour but de
condamner avant d'avoir vu c'est vrai
que c'est le retour de la télé réalité
est ce que sarah un avenir sur une patte
l'intérêt d'autres appellent à sa place
je suis désolé c'est hyper et
franchement aller voir parce que moi
j'ai vu la photo etc de la maison quand
on a négocié contre avait tout ils ont
tous montré ça va être un programme
exceptionnel et ça fait plaisir de voir
qu'une production met les moyens pour
faire un programme de qualité a déjà il
ya les moyens pour l'animation ça c'est
sûr